so it's been a while since I've made a
video on a Titan and having already
discussed for the six original brothers
were left of Oceanus and Kronos
hopefully as you can tell by today's
title the video will be an Oceanus the
titan god of the ocean Oceanus was
considered the titan god of the great
inception river Okeanos in ancient greek
cosmology the revoke jános or the river
Oceanus as son prefered was the
freshwater stream that encircled the
entire world both Homer and Hesiod refer
to Oceanus as the ocean stream all of
the rivers Springs and lakes through
their waters from this one River making
it the source of the Earth's fresh water
like all of the first generation of
titans
Oceanus was a child of the earth Gaia
and the heavens Uranus in some accounts
he was the oldest of all of their
children his wife was a tightness known
as death ease and in their union they
gave birth to many of the first Oceanos
as well as numerous rivers these rivers
were referred to as the Potter boy the
gods of the river these River gods will
normally depicted in one of three
different forms either as a man of the
head of a bull a bull horned man of a
serpentine fishtail or as regular men
holding pitchers of water the ocean
hands are of course the nymphs of the
sea and it's believed that Oceanus
fathered 3000 of them along with 3,000
pata muy so I think it's fair to say
they had more than quite a few children
many of the goddesses of the sea walls
are the offspring of Oceanus entities
including Thetis Metis and Amphitrite
the wife of Poseidon the physical
depictions of Oceanus do vary there is a
particularly old painting on a vase that
depicts him in a similar manner to his
children as a bull horn god of a
serpentine tail instead of legs and many
saw him as having both the attributes of
a fish in a serpent the same form shared
of the Potter Moy there are also some
Hellenistic and Roman mosaics and
statues that depict him as a muscular
bearded man but there are also
depictions of him with the claws of a
crab and the lower body of a serpent
there was a tale that originates from
Norfolk a myth that states the very
first titan king of the heavens was
known as affion eventually he would be
wrestled off his throne by Kronos and he
would throw it or fear into the ocean
there are some people that believe that
Ophion and oceanus are the same person
and with Oceanus being the oldest of the
titans is quite possible that he could
have thought the throne should have
belonged to him after losing unto his
brother Cronus he would have to settle
for being rule of the ocean before the
rule of the Olympians
overruled by Oceanus when the war
happened Oceanus did not take the sight
of his fellow Titans all the Olympians
instead he decided to withdraw from the
conflict completely when the war had
finished the seas were given to Poseidon
below Sheerness unlike many of his
brothers and sisters was not imprisoned
in Tartarus he was still allowed to
remain a patron of the sea Poseidon may
have overshadowed Oceanus but he was
still present respected and worshiped by
some as you would expect from the Lord
of the sea Oceanus is one of the Titans
that we do have a fair amount of
information on to his fellow Titans he
presented this outlawed figure because
he did not take part in the castration
of Uranus or the war of the Olympians to
his brothers and sisters it was clear
that his allegiance did not light with
them or perhaps he just did not care
hopefully I've been able to shed some
light on another one of the lesser known
deities of Greek mythology feel free to
share your thoughts on Oceanus with me
in the comments below as always I've
been your host mythologies fiction
explained